RELLY BRANDMAN: Hey developers.
I bet you're looking for ways
to increase your visibility
to users and break that
million download mark.
My name is Relly.
I'm a product manager on
Play's Search & Discovery team
and I'm here to help.
Visibility and
discoverability are
important for apps to reach
their users on Google Play.
For the average
app, search makes up
the majority of installs.
As an app developer,
when a user searches
for something that's
like your app,
you want them to
find your content.
Optimizing this process
means understanding
what type of searches
users are doing and making
sure that data for your app
supports these searches.
There are generally two types
of searches that users do.
The first type is
for users who know
exactly what
they're looking for.
For example, those
who will do a search
based on the title of your app.
And titles are not
just about branding.
It is important to be
as clear as possible
in the title to communicate
what the app is about.
Is your app about internet
radio, travel planning,
podcasting?
Making this clear in the title
will capture the attention
of interested users,
making your apps stand out
in a sea of competitors.
The second type
of search is done
by users who are not sure
exactly what they want
and search by keywords like the
features that are looking for.
For example, I
like puzzle games.
And well, I also like goblins.
Once you've gotten
the attention of users
and they've clicked
on your app, it's
all about your store listing.
Your app's description
should clearly
tell users what your app does
and why it matters to them.
Once that's done, you can
brag about how successful
your app is, what awards
you've won, and so on.
But as the saying
goes, a picture
is worth a thousand words.
There will be users out
there who judge apps
by the quality of their
screenshots and videos.
As such, a high quality app
will strive for high quality
screenshots and videos that
users can scan through.
The more you can communicate
what the experience is like,
the more likely it is that
users will download your app.
Keep in mind that you don't
have to do all the work when
it comes to search.
Google Play is constantly
collecting statistics
about installs, uninstalls,
install retention,
and engagement.
Apps that are successful
at all these metrics
are more likely to be highly
ranked in search results.
So the most important
thing you can do
is to create the best
experience for your users
no matter what your app does.
We all know those days that
you haven't had enough coffee
and you don't know exactly
what you're looking for.
Sometimes it's great to just
sit, browse through the store
without typing any searches,
and look for new awesome apps.
There are generally
two types of browsing.
The first is scanning
through the apps homepage
and the second is
through top charts.
When users open the Play store
and click on the apps option,
they're taken to what we
call the apps home page.
This page contains the
top charts as well as
the categories users
can look through,
for example, new and updated
apps, lifestyle apps,
and learning tools.
And the cool thing is this page
is personalized to each user.
The homepage browse
experience let's Google Play
offer new and interesting
apps to every user
no matter what
they're interested in.
And of course, there
are the top charts.
These lists, like Top Paid,
Top Free, and Top Grossing,
are common ways for
both new and returning
users to gain a
quick understanding
of the most popular apps.
You may be wondering
how your app can
get onto one of
these top charts.
Like any search or
discovery system,
we're constantly
tuning our algorithm
to provide the best
experience for users.
Top Paid, Top Free,
and Top Grossing
target new users or people
who just got a new device.
They're looking for the
best and most popular apps
as recommendations for
how to get started.
Top New Paid and Top New Free
target what's new and popular.
For that reason,
we limit it to apps
that have been
published recently.
Finally, the Trending
list highlights
apps that are moving faster than
we predicted in a recent day
moving window.
This list helps users find
what's really hot right now.
You've made an amazing app.
And now you know
more about what you
can do to maximize your
discoverability on Google Play.
To learn more, read our
developer guidelines
on developer.android.com.
Now go and break that
million user mark.
And thanks for watching.